des forçats de la livraison en pleine
épidémie
ludovic et pablo auto-entrepreneurs à
lyon font partie de la légion de jeunes
coursiers qui sillonne à vélo les rues
désertes de la capitale des gaules y
compris en ces temps de crise sanitaire
mais à la différence de nombre de leurs
collègues eux collent des affiches entre
deux commandes pour appeler à la grève
des livreurs dans plusieurs
agglomérations de l'hexagone
ludovic syndiqués à la cgt est
particulièrement sensible au quotidien
des travailleurs précaires dont il fait
partie pour lui les mesures de soutien
aux indépendants et aux pme mise en
place par le gouvernement ne sont pas
adaptés à la réalité du terrain
notre syndicat cgt ils appellent à la
grève place l indemnité qui est prévu
elle est accessible aux indépendants
dont les livreurs qui auront une baisse
de chiffre d'affaires de 70 %
donc c'est assez important et ils
annoncent qu'ils vont peut-être baissé à
50% mais encore une fois tous les livres
ils sont pas indemnisés quoi et ça c'est
un vrai problème parce que ça nous
pousse à travailler comme des forcenés
d'autant plus que ces mesures elles ont
été annoncées à la fin du mois les deux
livreurs s'inquiètent aussi de leurs
conditions de travail
dès l'hiver ou et humber it leur aurait
promis des gants et du gel
hydroalcoolique soit des produits
indispensables en cette période de crise
de covile 19 et qu'ils attendent
toujours
car il peine à respecter les distances
de sécurité notamment lorsque des
dizaines de livreurs s'entassent au tour
des restaurants lors de la préparation
des commandes
ludovic se dit préoccupé et pas
seulement pour lui on n'a aucune
sécurité déjà ne pas attraper le virus
mais ensuite de paille porteurs sains et
il refilé aux autres livreurs aux
travailleurs des restaurants et pas aux
patrons des restaurants qui se fasse en
sont bien chez eux ou même aux clients
quoi alors qu'on envoie des dizaines et
des dizaines chaque jour pour les deux
indépendants
la livraison à domicile n'a rien
d'essentiel et peut même confiné au
ridicule avec les promotions mises en
place par le beurre et des livres ou à
l'occasion du confinement les commandes
absurde se sont multipliées l'über des
livres eux et c'est pour maintenir la
demande
il met en place toutes sortes de
promotions moi ça m'est arrivé du pot
d'avoir comme commandes
de rosé à 6 km et c'est du confort quoi
pour les gens qui sont dans confinement
chez eux et c'est en occurrence en aucun
cas une question de nécessité en livre
pas des gens âgés qui sont chez eux
qu'ils peuvent pas faire les courses etc
on livre des cadres qui sont en
télétravail qui pourrait très bien
descendre pendant une heure aller faire
leurs courses pour la semaine entre les
peurs liées à l'épidémie de kobe 19 un
quotidien où la vitesse prime souvent
sur leur sécurité et des conditions
financières souvent précaires les
livreurs indépendant apportent aussi
leur contribution à la lutte contre le
coronavirus mais leur statut ne semble
pas constituer la priorité du moment